you have in mind something like a
Bitcoin future for if if money is broken
that's one of the potential fix is
something more market-based that
incentivizes saving rather than debt the
other vision of the future is something
of of our money's future is something
like cbdc Central Bank digital
currencies you describe this as a
surveillance and control mind set that
is gripping much of our ruling class can
you sketch
out what that Vision might look like and
why it's something best
avoided so over the past Century and a
half and really more than that most
efficiencies we make with money come at
the cost of centralization and more
surveillance um so we make money faster
and easier but it gets coalescent into
bank Banks and then central banks and
Central Bank digital currencies are kind
of like the the Capstone of that where
it's just fully surveilled it's kind of
fully locked in it's programmable by the
the state um privacy's basically just
completely lost at that point um and so
in that world it kind of helps maintain
the 160 different currency bubbles that
that countries have now it makes it hard
to for people to kind of Escape that
system now luckily in a world where
bitco stable coins exist um countries
you know assets can now Pierce each
other's borders which are hard to stop
um you know stable coins the United
States could stop easily but the
question is do they want to and and
certainly the Argentinas or the nigerias
of the world can't do anything about the
fact that stable coins exist Bitcoin can
potentially disrupt even the biggest
currencies in the long Arc of time and
and so we'll see how if it's up to that
challenge um but basically we we have
one of two directions either we can
Embrace some of the op Source technology
and allow more market-based
competition and it's not necessarily a
choice it's I think there's some degree
of technological determinism in the
sense that if this technology is robust
enough and desirable enough it's very
hard to overwhelm the market forces of
people that would want the these
Technologies um but if whatever reason
if the technolog is insufficient or if
it's kind of like killed in the Cradle
before it can really kind of fully
mature uh or set back a long period of
time one way or another um then we enter
a world of you know more centralized
control than we've been accustomed to
and then you can you know things like
you can use narratives around War you
can use narratives around um the
environment things like that to control
how people spend more on a regular basis
which is a a somewhat dystopian future
and it's not hard to imagine that more
places could be kind of like direction
that China goes in which is to have a
pretty significant top- down uh
enforcement and I think that's should be
generally resisted uh and that that
freedom of being able to use whatever
money you want basically freedom to
protect your own savings your own
accumulated time and energy uh uh should
be rewarded and I think it's useful for
people to understand these Technologies
either potentially to use them
themselves or to understand just the
macro context what what the existence of
these things mean so if if things like
Bitcoin and stable coins can Pierce
Financial borders in a way that hasn't
been useful hasn't been possible before
or what does that mean for you know
different countries in their ability to
maintain currencies what does it mean
for Global assets I think these are
questions that investors and just anyone
kind of interested in the subject should
be familiar with but I mean there's a
there's a movement against cbdcs against
Central Bank digital currencies but I'm
not sure that the average listener or
American exactly understands what it is
how it's different than just dollars
being digital there's you know a
programmable aspect to
cbdcs and that is the really dangerous
privacy violating part could you just
give a couple examples of why from your
perspective that would be an assault on
Liberty so it used to be that
transactions were naturally private like
handing over a bank note or gold coin or
silver coin was a private act uh but but
as things kind of Coes onto bank balance
sheets uh we we and then there's like
various laws that make those Banks
constantly give over the information to
the government we we kind of the the
natural Assumption of what is normal has
shifted kind of to be an anti-privacy
stance and cash is kind of the last
vestage of privacy um and of course it's
it's fairly controlled I mean try to go
to your bank and if you got $100,000 in
the account be like yeah I'd like to
take that out uh it's my money um you're
going to get a lot of push back uh
trying to take out very long large
amounts of cash from the system because
it's generally discouraged um and
because they don't like that much
private value going around even in some
countries buying above a little bit of
gold gets you basically kyc like uh you
get you get identified for having done
that um and so there's a lot of um and I
think this is like to the extent that
they attack Bitcoin I don't think it'll
be about things like Banning it it'll be
about things like Banning the private
usage of it or putting restrictions on
self- cussing it saying oh just just
hold it the Black Rock ETF you know just
fully fully put in these silos don't
hold it yourself that's that's that's
kind of the push back I think that's
going to happen hey thanks for watching
that clip from my conversation with Lynn
Alden about her new book broken money
you can watch another clip right here or
the full conversation over here